dr briand bonsoir bienvenue a découverte
en direct sommes très heureux de vous
recevoir parce qu'on veut connaître au
fond le passage s'il y en a un de la
pandémie allant des mii quels sont les
scénarios que vous envisagez
en fait c'est toujours très compliqué
parce que c'est difficile de prévoir le
futur mais en se basant sur les
expériences qu'on a sur d'autres virus
il ya climatiquement trois scénarios
possibles le premier le plus favorable
c'est que effectivement ce virus
devienne quelque sorte un virus
pandémique comme les autres quatre
autres coronavirus endémique que l'on
connaît qui va provoquer effectivement d
une maladie bénigne et qui va donc
circuler rapidement dans la population
le deuxième scénario c'est plutôt un
scénario qui ressemblerait à la grippe
et la grippe saisonnière comme vous
savez donc on a des épidémies et et
danser épidémie il ya des gens qui
malheureusement sont pas risque d'avoir
des formes graves de la maladie et d'en
mourir chaque année avec la grippe on
entre 6 450 mille six cent cinquante
mille personnes qui meurent chaque année
de la grippe donc ça demande quand même
un programme de lutte assez bien
organisé et le troisième scénario qui
est un peu le scénario catastrophe c'est
à dire qu'on va avoir d'autres variant
qui vont émerger qui seront différents
des variants qu'on connaît et donc ça va
demander qu'on met en cause les outils
qu'on a déjà c'est à dire qu'on revoie
un peu les vaccins les traitements etc
donc ça c'est scénario catastrophe on
l'espère absolument pas évidemment mais
il faut quand même toujours se préparer
et être vigilant et le premier scénario
c'est plus favorable aussi mais
malheureusement ne sait pas quand ça va
venir ça peut prendre quand même
plusieurs variantes à l'examen la
science a fait des progrès
extraordinaires depuis deux ans on nous
dit beaucoup justement que la
vaccination a sauvé peut-être l'un des
millions de personnes il reste que on
assiste encore à une course au vaccin
cette course au vaccin l'om est un
regard particulier vous fait un appel
aux scientifiques pour peta est orienté
cette course là de quoi at-on besoin
justement pour nous et des ajustements
dans ce scénario peut-être catastrophe
auquel on peut s'atteindre qu'on espère
qu'il n'arrivera pas
oui la course au vaccin en fait elle a
deux visages le premier visage c'est la
lutte contre les iniquités et s'assurer
que tout le monde ait accès aux vaccins
tous ceux qui en ont besoin et la
deuxième course effectivement cessé
d'avoir des meilleurs vaccins donc soit
des vaccins qui
justement une plus grande efficacité en
utilisant les plateformes qu'on a déjà
et qui sont déjà utilisés en particulier
par exemple en adaptant la composition
du vaccin ou variant qui circulent mais
aussi l'autre espoir qu'on a c'est
peut-être avoir un vaccin qui soit
beaucoup plus efficace sur la
transmission de la maladie pour
l'instant on a des vaccins qui sont très
bons pour prévenir les maladies graves
et protéger les gens les empêcher d'être
hospitalisée et de mourir mais on voit
bien que les vaccins qu'on a
actuellement ne sont pas aussi efficaces
que l'on aimerait sur la transmission
puisqu'on a encore beaucoup de cas et
spécialement avec au micro en même temps
vous avez évoqué l'inéquité vaccinale on
apprend aussi par le web est que des
millions et des millions de doses ont
été jetés littéralement parce que par la
raison de la crainte qu'ils soient
périmées dans certains pays
on en est ou sur cette équité ou
inéquité vaccinale
ont disons qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
progrès faits puisque le kovacs
annoncent qu'ils ont réussi à distribuer
pratiquement 1 milliard de doses dans
les pays en développement donc je pense
que ce le l'inéquité est en train de se
combler enfin en comble ce
déficit d'équité mais c'est vrai que
c'est cet art et puis il faut maintenir
absolument
la livraison de ces vaccins parce
qu'effectivement bon parfois on est pas
on ne peut pas utiliser tous les vaccins
qui ont délivré pour diverses raisons
des raisons logistiques des raisons
matérielles des raisons qui sont liées
aussi à la à la faiblesse des systèmes
de santé dans beaucoup de ces pays et
aussi le fait qu'il ya un absentéisme
dans l'est dans le secteur des soins qui
fait qu' on peut pas nécessairement
vacciner aussi vite que vous voudrez
toute la population donc se tenir compte
aussi de tous ces empêchements qui sont
liées à la pandémie
lié à des déficits structurels aussi
dans certains pays et donc cher avec
tout ça pour essayer de s'améliorer en
continu mais je crois quelque chose que
certains dans l'esprit des spécialistes
de ms et vous dr briand c'est qu'on ne
peut pas contrer cette pandémie qu'avec
des doses de rappel nous ici on en est à
la troisième
certaines villes une ville au canada en
est à la quatrième dose est ce qu'on
aura en scène est cinquième une sixième
dos c'est pas la voie à suivre selon
vous
non non tout à fait parce que d'abord
c'est très coûteux et puis c'est
embêtant et en plus on a on ne comprend
pas très bien non plus les effets à long
terme d'avoir des doses répétées de
vaccins donc on pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux de se pencher plutôt sur le
produit le vaccin lui-même et voir
comment pour améliorer le produit pour
que justement l'immunité conférée par la
vaccination durent plus longtemps et
aussi nous permettre d'éviter toutes les
formes de la maladie pas seulement
l'histoire en terminant vous avez évoqué
des trois scénarios mais violent on
espère le premier on pourrait vivre le
troisième cancer et avec quel signal
pourrons-nous d'urbain conclure on est
passé de la pandémie allant des nippes
et quel est le plus grand progrès que
vous espérez pour la science pour mettre
fin à cette pandémie
alors c'est difficile de donner des
dates et et c'est parce que comme vous
avez compris le virus s'adapte et nous
aussi on s'adapte donc aussi un petit
peu comme ça un marathon en fait je
pense qu'on est on est certainement dans
les derniers kilomètres de ce marathon
mais je ne sais pas encore je vois pas
encore la ligne d'arrivée ça c'est clair
ce qui est sûr c'est que dans notre
boîte à outils pour lutter contre la
pandémie on a de plus en plus d'outils
on a tous ces vaccins y en a encore
beaucoup qui sont à l'état de deux
phases près qu'il est prêt mise sur le
marché en tous les cas et donc on va
certainement dans les mois à venir aussi
avoir plus de vaccins plus
d'opportunités donc tu crois qu'on est
vraiment sur la pente favorable mais
très difficile de prévoir donc je pense
que les progrès pour la science ce qu'on
espère c'est vraiment justement que on
est des meilleurs vaccins que ce soit
avec les plateformes actuelles ou
d'autres plateformes qui pourraient
arrivé dans le futur des meilleurs
traitements aussi qu'on en ait plus à
tous les stades de la maladie et on
aimerait aussi avoir des tests qui
puisse servir dans différentes
circonstances notamment des tests
rapides qu'ils soient beaucoup plus
fiable comme ça on pourrait en fait
ajouté à notre boîte à outils et faire
en sorte que même si cette maladie reste
encore une maladie grave qui
malheureusement tu encore des gens on
pourrait apprendre dans notre monde du
xxième siècle la ville de mieux en mieux
avec est justement réduire son impact
non seulement sur la santé mais aussi
sur nos sociétés alors je retiens de tas
brillant qu'on doit rester très prudent
on doit rester quand même optimiste et
donc en ce sens garder espoir pour cette
année 2022 dr murray merci beaucoup tout
à fait donc merci beaucoup au revoir